so Nick pick Vanessa last night with all
the hugs and tears but was it me or was
it the most force finale in bachelor
history a lot of fans are wondering if
they even like each other alright I
gotta admit it was a little awkward and
alright super awkward between the gun
with him on the show and it didn't get
any better when we talked to them this
morning Vanessa Grimaldi will you marry
me we almost forgot to exchange numbers
before I left the house in Finland were
like oh my god okay what's your number
our relationship so far has been me
dating 29 other women and then having to
watch that back while having a
relationship long-distance and I think I
don't know if you think that might be
easy the thought it has been four months
since they got engaged they've been in
the same room only a handful of times
and already there's a rumor they've
broken up so could that explain all that
awkward body language that happened
after the final rose do you feel like
you're a team absolutely are Nick and
Vanessa just not that into each other I
mean it's nice seeing you guys sitting
you're holding hands it's very nice to
someone you know bachelor nation went
into overdrive on social media one post
that when you made a bad decision but
it's too late to go back so you just
have to ride it out what are your fears
now today for your relationship I think
my fear would be it not working out and
then where did you and your fiance first
make love Finland and Finland it is
the couple was a little more
affectionate on Kimmel her hand on his
knee and he kept rubbing her shoulder
like a lie but what does Nick have to
say about fellow bachelor Chris soules
calling him out Nick wants to be famous
he loves being famous he loves the
spotlight really truly does if he would
admit that he's lying chris is a friend
chris is a way with words sometimes do
you want to be famous actually no when
you do eventually get married would you
televise the wedding never really
discussed I mean I don't I don't want to
speak for like I don't think we're
against the idea but again I think those
are conversations that we'd have to have
know once we you know decided to have a
wedding any I Do's will have to wait
next week Nick starts Dancing with the
Stars where he is paired with new mom
and Max's fiance Peta Murgatroyd so is
Vanessa jealous
nope she's been very supportive um she's
I think might be slightly more excited I
am what are you in PETA what's your vibe
almost like brother and sister like
she's a goofball I'm a goofball so we
feel like our like team chemistry is so
Dancing is next for Nick but how about
the woman he rejected last night Raven
well she is heading to bachelor in
paradise
you